[Music]
this
is star talk i'm neil degrasse tyson
your personal astrophysicist
i serve as the director of new york
city's hayden planetarium
part of the american museum of natural
history right here in manhattan
this as cosmic queries you know who my
co-host is chuck
what's up neil oh thanks for being there
in arms reach
of digital arms reaching digital arms
reach yes exactly i feel your zeros and
ones kind of touching my face
right now there you go uh
base two zeros and ones that's right you
know what the topic is today
interspecies communication ah
that's just creepy well it's i mean it's
beautiful but
it's gorgeous not not as gorgeous as
interspecies dating but hey what are you
going to do
what are you going to do i don't know
what that means
what we have is one of the world's
experts on this who is a professor
of psychology at hunter college and
is in the animal behavior and
comparative psychology
doctoral program at the graduate center
of cuny the city university of new york
the one and the only professor diana
reese diana welcome to star talk
well hi thanks for having me today ed
you've been out in our backyard the
whole time we've been having star talk
and where you been
i'm here in new york here's you just
right there
you've been talking to other animals i
think that's it yeah instead of your own
damn species all right
yep i've been hanging out with dolphins
so let me just get the audience to know
you a little better
you have a a a ted talk where you share
the platform with others who were trying
to create something big
and what was that yeah back in uh 2013
my three colleagues we said my partners
on this
um were peter gabriel the musician and
visionary vint cerf
who is the co-founder of the co-father
of the internet
that's right the co-founder of the
internet and um neil gershenfeld
who's the director of the mit center for
bits and
atoms okay so no matter what you guys
talked about in that ted video
it seems to me you have the power
knowledge and wisdom to make it happen
yeah given that list it's it's
they're they're a great group of people
to work with and we've been working
together
uh with where we have this idea it was
actually peter gabriel who started
this idea and then approached the three
of us um and the idea
is that how is how can we use technology
um our our new technologies
along with ideas that we have to bridge
the gap
in terms of communication with other
animals we share this planet with
lots of other species obviously they
have brains
they're all communicating we just can't
crack their codes
so one of the ideas behind the
interspecies internet is
coming up with new interfaces so that we
can communicate with these other species
creating artificial codes or devices
that allow them
a voice is the is the simplest way of
saying it and then we can use these
shared codes to communicate
the other aspect of it is is finding new
ways
to decode or to decipher the signals
that they're all using amongst
themselves so that's the basic idea
so you wouldn't you have to define
communication
first because i mean when you talk about
all these different species
let's just take for instance some
insects their language is
chemical so you know what
what is language what is communication
jacques you just nailed the big question
the big question and the thing that's so
under such debate
so the questions first of all are we the
only species that use
a kind of communication that we say is
language where we use
signals that are meaningful and that
refer to things in the environment we
call those referential signals
so when i point to an apple i'm using a
symbol i'm using a word
that doesn't look anything like an apple
but it refers to that and we can use
that
in a shared way to communicate now bees
the little bees were actually the first
species
in which that someone actually decoded
some of their communication
and got a nobel prize for it this was a
long time ago
because they twerk that's how that's how
they talk to each other they twerk
they're like yo i check it out
thanks for letting me know that bees
twerk
that's a way of saying it chuck but it's
true they move their wiggle they shake
their bodies they do this
waggle dance or shake their booty dance
right
and they communicate not only where food
is outside their hive
but the distance from the hive and they
believe it or not
they these little bees with just you
know with
a little brain are communicating changes
in the location
of the food base and they have to track
the distance of the food from the sun
but guess what as you know
what's happening with the sun moves well
rotates
earth is rotating so the disc the sun is
moving to them
and uh they have to track that and they
they keep that interest they keep that
in their communication it's amazing it's
amazing these little bees do that
that's why they're always following
cardi b
so diana you literally wrote the book on
on some of this you
uh back about 10 years ago i have the
title
the dolphin in the mirror exploring
dolphin minds
and saving dolphin lives so you you've
been
your professional career is invested in
trying now now dolphins have way bigger
brains than
do bees so presumably you chose them
because of whatever similarities you can
align with humans is that right yeah i
mean it's interesting my background
believe it or not was in theater i was
actually a set designer for many theater
theater
thank you we won't we won't go there in
too much detail
but um i i was always really fascinated
by animals and i had an academic
background i wound up taking extra
courses
going back for my phd and i was reading
about um whales getting slaughtered
about these
you know the whaling in general and i i
already knew i wanted to study animal
behavior and i
started looking up what we knew about
whales and dolphins and at the time it
wasn't
there wasn't that much known it was in
the late 70s
and i i never watched flipper i wasn't a
flipper fan i used to watch lassie
and um but the more i learned about
dolphins i thought wow
these are really big-brained complex
animals and we don't know very much
about them they seem to be complex
in terms of these societies and the seas
we didn't know much about their
communication systems but again they
have these big magnificent brains what
are they doing with it it's bigger than
our brain right
they're bigger than our brains but their
bodies are bigger than our bodies
so when we think about brain size and
think about it relative to
body size it's called the get ready for
this one the
encephalization quotient or eq
it's brain size relative to body size so
dana where
are humans on this encephalization
quotient yeah
so our brains are
seven times the size they would need to
be to run a body of our size
okay because we think we're talking
about body body
weight body the body weight and the
brain weight
okay the brain size that way so our
brain is seven times think about it as
our brain being seven times the size it
needs to run a body of our size
for dolphins they have a brain that's
about
four and a half uh 4.2 or 4.3 if you
want to get really specific
times the size it needs to be to run a
body of that size
most animals are have the value of
one it their brain is just the right
size to run
a body of that size okay in terms of
metabolism and everything
so so those butt heads on star trek the
guys with the big giant butt heads
they're really smart right they're super
i mean they're like the smartest
people in the universe really big brains
okay so yeah so it gives us a sense now
if we look at
you know abs if we think about brains
though
it's still a huge mystery in terms of
what this with a recipe is
for being more intelligent you know more
to have more intelligent is it the
number of neurons
is it the organization of a brain is it
you know how the how it's all connected
so that's still a mystery just turns out
that if we look at
animals that show uh complex social
interactions and uh have a lot of
complexity in their behavior
they tend to be these animals that have
these uh
really high values in eq so those
animals are animals like uh cetaceans
which are whales and dolphins
the great apes elephants along with us
humans
and then it you know it varies when you
look at that sort of whole scale
i always thought apes were great i i
always thought so it was really smart
yeah you know i knew a great ape once
it was great he was great but did you
get started in this at right around the
time when
dolphins were getting trapped in tuna
nets and this was a whole huge outcry
for in the fishing industry about this i
i started a little bit before that i
i started about i started studying
dolphins in the early 80s late actually
even the late 70s
but i actually worked on that project to
try to stop dolphins from getting
caught in the tuna nets that was a big
issue as a scientist i do science for
learning you know the basic basic
science
but then i think it's really important
to apply that to do what we call
translational science
and apply it to really help protect
those animals in conservation and
welfare
and stop these horrible situations all
right why
didn't anyone try to protect the tuna
somehow it was okay a netflix dolphins
are not
delicious well oh no i'm very serious
diana
yeah is it aren't you being speciesist
here
you're saying oh protect the dolphin eat
the tuna
they're both big fish in the ocean and
you're dividing it up
and you're showing preferences what's
going on here
you're making really good points neil so
first of all dolphins are mammals we
know that
and fish and there's and what we know
about dolphins right now and i'm not
going to say we shouldn't be
protecting fish species because it's
really important
to protect all species on the planet so
they can continue to survive
i want to say that right up but with
dolphins these are
large-brained highly social self-aware
meaning self-aware and socially aware
animals that feel pain and they can
suffer
and they were treated in this way in the
tuna nets where they'd get
stuff they would be such a drowned
people were trapped drowned
they would replace them because they
like us and uh again it was
it was just a horrendous situation okay
so you're but you're admitting that
you're
you you you more highly value mammals
than non-mammal vertebrates no it's just
that
can dolphin does not sound
or taste good no we're not going there
it's not a thing and it shouldn't be a
thing okay having some of this flipper
salad
people in certain countries are still
eating dolphin
oh no and eating whale even though yeah
absolutely so in japan
i don't know if you saw the film the
cove
it wasn't it's on my list it's on my
list very important didn't that win
academy award for documentary
or was it it was in the running if it
didn't win no no it won the academy
award for the best documentary
i worked on that film i was a science
advisor and i was actually the person
that told the director about the
situation because
many of my colleagues and i have been
trying to stop these horrible drive
hunts in japan
where dolphins are herded h-e-r-d-e-d
heard herded um using a method where
they create an acoustic
uh an acoustic barrier it's called
oikomi and they bang on pipes and they
scare the dolphins into this cove
when they're there and afterwards
they're slaughtered some of the dolphins
are still taken
to um specific aquariums most aquariums
in the world
absolutely oppose this and have been
working to stop it
but some aquariums in japan china and a
few other countries
procure their dolphins from these drive
hunts and these animals
are are are then taken and the rest of
the group
is killed and they're killed absolutely
in the most inhumane manner
you can imagine they shouldn't be killed
at all but when you see how they're
killed
everybody who would see this would want
to stop it and it means but
let's say they found a humane way to
kill them you're still
preferring to protect the life of fellow
mammals
than fellow non-mammal vertebrates as
a let me say this as a marine mammal
scientist i feel like
it i need to have a voice in this
political arena and yes i think that for
dolphins
they shouldn't i can say clearly these
animals need protection they shouldn't
be killed
then we duke it out at the at the
science conference because i want to
protect my tuna right
and the tuna scientist loses every time
because
tuna stupid and delicious
well let's let let's try this one what
if we could
make sure that the population that we're
conserving tuna populations
and when they are captured it's done in
the most humane way possible
that's the win-win so why don't you
apply for that
they love it yeah that's the way to do
it yeah it's a tough
so i think we have to be humane if we're
still eating animals and i think that's
really critical
so that's true across the spectrum of
america across the spectrum
yes absolutely as a marine mammal
scientist i speak out about the dolphins
because that's where my
area of expertise is but i really vote
for all adam i would rather that
nobody's eating
any animals to tell you the truth that's
what my big push is but
you know people then you have to deal
with the people who want to protect
plants
many years ago i worked at the wildlife
conservation society you know we're
five zoos and i ran the animal
enrichment program and i was running a
dolphin research lab there
and my husband used to joke he said you
can't have anybody she works with over
for dinner
because you can't eat anything either
they work with that animal
or it's a plant that they're cultivating
so there's nothing
going on you just have to live off the
air right and that that's all that's the
best
that you can do well chuck i think we
don't have time in this segment for q
and a we'll
we'll start right up in segment two okay
you got your questions lined up so
listen
from the internet you got them all there
okay
so when we come back more with the
behavioral
animal psychologist diana reese and
chuck nice bring in the questions we'll
be right back
we're back star talk cosmic queries
co-host chuck nice
hey hey tweeting as chuck nice comic
still thank you sir
okay nice comment yes and our expert
today
on inter-species communication diana
rhys diana
welcome back to star talk thanks and
we've got questions for you solicited
from our fan base
all across the social media platforms so
chuck what do you have
okay well of course you know we always
start with the patreon patron because
they support us financially and quite
frankly they pay us yes
yes there's no better support okay no
better support
there's no better nation than a donation
anyway uh
this is kyle marston from patreon
um hey thanks for the kind of weird
hashtag
cq inner species and how could we use
the periodic table of elements
and chemistry to communicate with life
that demonstrates the capacity
for the classification of potentially
intelligent as an alphabet
person man woman camera
tv might be considered
um i'm not sure that reference so
so let me let me see if i can re-word
that question
all right so we have the periodic table
of elements highly organized
achievement of our understanding of the
nature of
matter and materials in the world if we
have an
alien and we want to communicate with
them do you see value
in organizing information in this
similar way
from information that we overlap with
them so that we can possibly come to a
common vocabulary
is it that i think that's what they're
asking their chuck is it
yeah i mean it's yeah if we use the
periodic table of elements as our own
sort of reference
that's that's our preference right right
i mean that's i don't know i'm going to
follow up
with a question but i guess this is more
for neil like
would that be the same everywhere i mean
the stuff would be the same
everything we understand about chemistry
tells us that if they were far enough
along
they would have the periodic table of
elements or have something more advanced
that we haven't come to yet
okay but that they would certainly have
that organization yes
okay so diana what what can you tell us
yeah about organizing information and
use that as a
foundation to communicate right so first
of all carl i want to thank carl for
that question because it's a really cool
question
so if you're face to face let's say
we're coming face to face
or face to tentacle with an alien
because we don't know
right no aliens have tentacles of course
and of course they well
as as we've seen recently in some in
some films
um you know one of the beginning things
is we have to figure out what their
sensory systems are
okay if we're face to face there's and
and what kinds of signals may be
perceived by each of us
so there's a lot there's a lot of um
first steps that we have to take now
if in communication and we can come back
to that in a minute
i'm assuming now that we're talking
about that we've received some kind of
signal and we're not face to face from
what from carl's question
and that they've sent us something that
we have deciphered as the periodic table
or an equivalent
of the periodic table is that am i on
the right here
or is is the organization of the
periodic table
useful to bring other kinds of
communication to bear
on on that encounter yeah so i mean if
we know that we have some
shared point of reference that the
universe is organized in this particular
way
then we have to find a way of letting
them know we're perceiving their signal
it's meaningful to us in that way
and giving them a signal back to say yes
this has been received
here is the equivalent for us and now
you're trying to align
your knowledge bases okay because what
what
the question i keep on i think i i keep
on having about this is
what is it in their signal that we've
gotten
that that lets us know that they have
this organization now the other aspect
of it is the question is
we can say we are going to make the
assumption
and i think this is what you're saying
neil that we have a common
knowledge base of the universe if we're
both intelligent species
then we can encode something in a way or
we have to try to encode something in a
way
that would be perceivable to another
we'd have to either find
use math and assume they know our math
or know our chemistry
and try to set up that communication
where we're showing equivalence
and use that as a bridge it gets into a
common
knowledge or something that's shared and
finding the right way to share it
and that's not trivial well it's not but
i love the
fact that you know as you guys are
talking so i'm seeing atoms and
molecules as like a base
and so i'm asking this would atoms
and molecules look the same to everyone
in the universe
as they do to us chuck you just said
one of the biggest questions for me is
look what if
other this other intelligence doesn't
see
doesn't even see i mean we're making the
assumption
that sight that vision is going to be
one of the main ways this creature would
sense the world i mean it just seems
it's
we're such visual creatures what if
they're not using sight as their main
sense
or it's not the same kind of site they
have different receptors
and we're very physiologically biased is
what you're saying absolutely
so how would you connect that to uh
chuck you probably have another question
related to this but
when you try to talk to dolphins um
we can't compare periodic tables of
elements we can't say this is an apple
what is your
what's your word for apple we can't do
that so
what is what overlaps that even empowers
you to even
ask the audacious question let's start
uh with something that we have in common
and what would you where would you go
from there
let me jump to the film arrival for a
minute because i think that could
illustrate the point i don't know if
there's
a few the couple of films name arrival
you mean the one where the alien visited
i think they both were but the one with
the the septa pod
the heptapods yeah the peptopods come
down
and um there's the scientists the link
thank you chuck for that
vision like that that was my that was my
heptapod uh
put us his fingers up into the camera
and pretending you're not squirting ink
though
the um um this linguist is is
approached by the government and they
say hey decode
these aliens start communicating with
them find out what they want here you
know because they're they're they're
trying they're scared this is an alien
that's
that's landed a bunch of aliens have
landed and
she says wait wait wait a minute we've
got to back up
it not that fast and when she's
completely right
if you're trying to communicate first of
all you have to have some sense
of who they are what their sensory
systems are like
so she spent weeks just watching them
trying to interact with them
creating something in common so they
could start sharing and that was
critical it was
very very important and insightful by
the writers the writer of the original
story
that it's not just oh you start
communicating it doesn't happen that way
it doesn't happen that way with dolphins
sometimes you'll have a breakthrough
with the dolphin rather quickly and i'm
going to tell you a story about one of
those breakthroughs that happened really
quickly
okay in a few minutes but you know she
had she watched them
and she started also imitating what they
were doing
imitation is a wonderful way to start
communicating
so it's if we go to another film
like close encounters of the third kind
that's what happened when they were
started
when they started communicating with the
aliens remember the sounds that the
alien
ship was producing
what did we do the people who were on
earth started imitating that
that kind of musical note and that
musical composition
and they were suddenly in sync they were
communicating i recognize you
i'm repeating back what you do that's
the beginning of communication
i'm imitating you and repeating it back
now i want to jump to a dolphin
situation
wait before you before you give your
dolph an example just back to the
arrival
movie for a second am i so wrong to
think
that i would not have sent a linguist
and a physicist i would have sent an
astrobiologist and a cryptographer
could you tell me what a linguist has
over a cryptographer
in that situation
because clearly they thought about that
as you say they
they they they knew what they were doing
for their storyline it just would not
have been my first thought
it wouldn't have been my first thought
either and i think
personally i would have sent a
cryptologist
and someone who studies communication in
other animals
and an astrophysicist means like you i
would have yeah
i have found your vice president and
it's me
it didn't have to be me but it should be
somebody who has some experience with
just like you yes but somebody yeah in
that realm
i've actually yeah i actually i actually
did some work with
with a seti project many years ago
talking about that this is a great
training ground
uh when we study species other species
don't worry diana we would have sent you
too so don't worry about it yeah we
gotta wait
we got your back on this okay thanks
guys thank you so much what's your
dolphin story
yeah so we're talking about imitation
and when i i had
what i call my first encounter with a
dolphin mind
okay and i was a graduate student at the
time and i was just starting my research
and i was working with this young
dolphin named cersei and i was
asked to teach her uh to just stay with
me in front of me
and eat fish that had been that were
three times the size of her head
and uh they were frozen dead fish that
were now defrosted so she could eat them
and i thought well this is too big to
give this dolphin so i cut them into
heads
middles and tail sections a little
cersei readily ate
the heads she ate the middle she spit
out every tail
and i looked at them and they had fins
spiny fins so i cut off the fins
thinking maybe they would be more
palatable
and then she ate everything now in the
course of training her to stay with me
while i was feeding her
if she broke station that's this term we
use that means they leave
before you want them to i would give her
a timeout which meant i would back away
about 15
10 to 15 feet from the pool and and it
broke
her ability to interact or get fish and
then i just stand there and look at her
and then i would come back and punish
her that's a punishment well it's a kind
of a it's a way to say you've done the
wrong thing
okay you can think about it as a
punishment but it wasn't i didn't think
about it that strongly i had to say
because i didn't have a shared code
you've done something wrong and this was
a technique
that many people used with animals at
the time we don't use it so much anymore
you sort of say
you just back away negative
reinforcement yeah
yeah yeah it's not it's not that you're
inflicting harm
on wrongdoing you're just removing
something that she was enjoying
exactly in that moment okay exactly so i
would back away and
again it could be for several seconds or
you know 10 to 15 seconds you know five
seconds i varied it
and then i would come back and she
learned hey something's wrong
you know and it would get corrected and
she was a really smart dolphin
and she learned very quickly don't leave
until i go like this at the end and it
means every and i'd show her an empty
bucket and everything's
done um again she was young and i had to
teach her this
for not for me but for the people who
where i was working
so everything's going fine cersei's
eating all the fish she's basically
trained me to cut her fish just the
right way i used to joke about that
and um now one day by accident i
happened to give her
an uncut tail and cersei looked up at me
her eyes got really big
she spit it out and she bolted across
the pool
and took a vertical position and just
stayed there across the pool and stared
at me
oh yeah oh and i get she gave you a
timeout
so that's where you need that music yeah
at the time the mexican i mean the
western standoff
so what's going on here i mean she's is
she really doing this
it's an anecdote it's a one observation
but as a scientist
i thought wow if she's really imitating
and
using this to communicate to me that i'm
doing something wrong like i commuted
communicated to something you know
something to her that's really pretty
amazing
so but i couldn't do anything with one
and n of one so what i did was i
set up an experiment where i was very
careful to feed her properly and give
her all perfectly cut fish
over the next couple of sessions she
never did it and then on purpose
three on three different occasions i
gave her an uncut tail and each time
she went across the pool and did this to
me that's the beginning
of communication that's how it starts
and again it's based on this idea i
talked to you about
she's observing me she's really smart
and she's using something
i do back and there have been cases like
so she she called the timeout on you
is what happened i think she did and and
and i actually wrote this up
better to cut my fish like that that's
right i trained you to serve me
how many times i'm going to teach you
how to it's so hard to get good help
these days
stupid humans they don't even know how
to cut a fish tail
what can i tell you so i learned my
lesson from that but i also
wrote a chapter on this in my doctoral
dissertation it was probably the best
chapter in the whole thing i think that
was the best one and it
was because i partnered with her she
gave me this idea
and it's really fascinating because i
think these are really smart smart
creative animals who are watching us
they're communicating back
and often it's a problem that we just
don't have the means
or the system that we can look at it
where we can show people scientifically
they understand these sounds these
symbols and they can use them and that's
right
i saw a comic once it might have been in
the new yorker
where these two dolphins are swimming
and
one says to the other speaking of humans
one says to the other
you know they face each other and make
noises but it's not clear they're ever
actually communicating with each
other the dolphin analysis of humans
yes and that's very much what we do with
most other animals to tell you
we got to take another break we only got
to one question in that segment chuck
who cares it's such a great conversation
all right when we come back
we'll see if we can bang out more than
one question in the segment
on inter-species communication with
professor diana reese
when we return
cosmic queries star talk
interspecies communication diana reese
so diane if someone wants to see more
beyond this
episode how do they get uh get connected
okay they can go whether or not they're
human by the way
i welcome all
so so where's the best place for them to
land for the uh they can look at
interspecies dot
io yes and for my research with my
colleague marcelo magnasco who's a
professor
at rockefeller university they can put
in reese
m2c2 and it will get them there
rhys r i e s s at r e
r e i s s d i s m yeah
r e i s s m2c2 and it will get them to
the website our website
excellent excellent well chuck this is a
cosmic queries and you've only delivered
me
one and a half questions so far well and
they were they were so good
you got to up your game okay all right
let's go let's get to this
let's call the whole segment a lightning
round okay all right all right let's do
it
so dan you have to answer as though this
is the evening news and you have to give
me a sound bite
super short okay okay go tor and
wellington from patreon says what kind
of nonverbal communication is already
common between humans and other species
is it more common than we think i know
my cat wants to go outside
when he starts scratching the door
better that than him scratching your
face
so we might split between domestic
animals and the rest of the animal
kingdom so what do you say there
diana yeah so animals are communicating
with us all the time
and we're communicating back these are
not part of science studies it's basic
communication
they watch us we watch them and we get
the more familiar we are
the more we learn to interpret that so
your cat or your dog
is watching you it's reading your
behavior you're doing the same that's
communication
how about they want when they want to be
subtrafugal and they want to deceive you
that's a whole other situation okay
deception deception
is not it's not well studied in the
non-human animal world yet but it's
really
interesting the reason why i ask is um
you know i was visiting someone's home
and they have a sign there
because they have a lot of dogs and the
dogs always sit and beg while you're
eating dinner
the sign says the dog has been fed
don't believe is [ __ ]
[Laughter]
the dog will look at you like it's never
been fed in his whole life oh
i think our pets do this a lot my cat
goes to my husband and looks like i
haven't been fed in five days
you know i just fed the cat you just but
they know not to go to you because you
you don't put up with that
my cat also does it to me later if my
coffin doesn't my cat does it when my
husband has just fed them
as well see that's diabolical thinking
it's not just animals i have three
children and they are
the same thing okay so all right this is
uh
this is colton judd colton says my
question is on
frbs since we've detected them we've
gotten quite a few over the years
how confident are you that any of these
could be communication from an advance
of alien civilization in a different
galaxy or solar system is that possible
i am also a huge fan of the show i think
it's
awesome and you guys are doing great
work okay
excellent so that so diana that turns
out to be a question for me these are
uh frb's are short for fast radio bursts
and so there are two things we have to
consider here either
it's a new phenomenon
in the universe that we don't have prior
data
to inform us on and so we should study
it
or it's intelligent aliens trying to
send us a signal okay
and every time we have a new telescope
that has new capabilities and
and new powers we discover stuff that
we've never seen before
that's very natural so if i'm a betting
person i would say it's probably some
new phenomenon
that we have yet to classify and
understand
and that'll be i'll think that it's that
before i will think that it's
intelligent aliens beaming signals at us
and that's why we can't answer them
because neil is like
this is not the communication and
they're like why won't you
answer us because neil will not let us
answer you it's all my fault okay
[Laughter]
i'm sure you have to check with
everybody you know too on the planet
who's listening
and making sure it's not coming from a
source that we know yeah
look the chuck will come visit visit uh
earth and say
where's that guy neal tyson
dude how come you're calling yo i was
texting you man how can you keep
ignoring my texts
all right all right let's move forward
uh let's keep it going keep it going
keep it going
um oh wow this is a great one douglas
stern says do we have any idea
how swarms of fish communicate like when
they form
a tight-knit ball to avoid predators
well at least the ones on the inside
avoid the president
let me tell you the ones on the outside
of that ball aren't having such a good
go of it
uh how do they know to stay in such
perfect formation
and dance and weave in unison hopefully
humans would need uh to mimic this
behavior
when the aliens come
so diana do we really
know everything we should know about how
even species communicate with themselves
enough to give me confidence that you
are making progress
in inter-species communication
because if we if we don't know why birds
flock and other kind of emergent
phenomena
but you're trying to find out how we can
communicate with another species
is that putting the cart in front of the
horse yeah it's a good question neil so
i think what
if they kind of go hand in hand with
each other looking trying to decode
community communication what we call
interest in trust species communication
between the species
when i see a termite colony there's a
million termites and they all
seem to know what they're doing because
at the end of the day
they love gossip that's how they do it
termites that's what's really happening
you cannot shut those termites up
they uh that's what's really happening
so yeah i mean there are a lot of there
are a lot of studies right now that have
been that are going on now that have
gone
on to try to decode the species own
signals and
we do that too with dolphins we try to
understand how they're using their own
signals
and then when we make those steps into
inner species communication between us
and dolphins we try to incorporate
signals
that they may find meaningful or useful
again
we'll develop a relationship with them
and then we're we're not using human
words we don't want i don't want to use
words with them they can't produce words
we've created for example we've created
an underwater keyboard and now a touch
screen
that gives them visual forms that we
know they can see
and then we if they touch those forms on
a
touch screen they hear a whistle or
that they can hear they can imitate and
they get specific things so we meet them
halfway using
their code so so you have a giant ipad
for dolphins
you know what you know that's going to
lead to dolphin tinder you know that
swiping you know there's going to be
dolphins swiping right now
actually we've watched them do that
movement the swiping
but we when we first gave them the
keyboard the touchscreen
it's a four by eight foot touch screen
it's actually an optical touch screen
if they touch it it their touch is
actually seen by cameras
so it's optically sensed
first day they saw this we did a we did
what we called
whacka fish not whack-a-mole to see if
it would work and we had fish going
across the screen
they one of the young dolphins who had
never seen anything
technical like this just immediately
started touching all the fish she looked
like a teenager going for the fish
he was great so just to be clear when in
the technology
their nose touching the screen is not
what you're sensing you have cameras
that are triangulating on where the nose
touch and that gives it a coordination
correct and just just to be it's not
their nose their nose is actually their
blowhole that's at the back of their
head
it's the beaker the rostrum that touches
that one right now um so
wait wait so that's not their nose in
the front no no that's the rostrum
that's the rostrum or beak
and you know what here's why no here's
why nobody will call it that
because you got well not you diana
biologists named one of the dolphins
a bottle-nosed dolphin thank you there
it is
okay okay so how about we why don't we
agree to call it it's snoot how about
that
it's snout if they could call it out
snap i'll give you that
yeah we're on the same page okay we're
now communicating
we have some interest species there's
hope for us here okay
uh that's great okay let's go to tim
word he's a patreon patron who says this
what tools or techniques
are used to discover communication in
the animal world
especially i wonder how we really know
what we
understand an animal is trying to tell
us ah so
yeah like it's pretty easy to know that
an animal understands us it's hard for
us to know if we understand
them you know um so
what are the tools that say this is how
we know
yeah well it's not easy and we use
cameras we use video cameras we use
recording to other kinds of recording
devices to record their sound
to record uh movement and then we try to
see how they use their how they use
sound and movement
and perhaps smell the different senses
in their social interactions so that's
one way but it's laborious i mean people
it takes
years to try to understand what signals
uh what signals go with what behaviors
and again but these this is what we use
we have to use our powers of
observation and sometimes it's just our
eyes and our ears and watching that's a
good way to start
but then we use other recording devices
and then we use computers
and we use big data analysis now
hopefully will help us
you know coupled with us to have
breakthroughs in learning about the
patterns that these animals use
every time i see a nature documentary
and the animal's doing some weird
behavior they always say
oh it's a it's a mating ritual maybe
maybe they're just trying to order pizza
you know
it's so funny you're right it it is
always
[Laughter]
but you know so animals communicate
about mating they commute about
finding food but they always they also
are doing a whole lot more than we ever
expected
and the more studies that we we read
about
we realize wow we never thought that
animals have alarm calls
and that other animals will listen to
like who's in the environment which
predators in the environment and then
it helps them know what escape route to
go to
or you know each other freddie's back
freddie the bully is back
you know there you go right but you know
just
if i can share an observation with you i
i grew up in the city in new york city
and so
the sounds of the city are actually
rather soothing to me
and traffic and alarm horns and sirens
and people and the bar spills out into
the street
this this is the sounds of my own
species and i'm actually quite comforted
when i hear it
i go into the wilderness in the woods
and i've hear people say oh it's so
peaceful
i say no it's not there's like crickets
and cicadas and
there's all this noise every animal is
talking to every other animal and you
find that soothing
i find that annoying which is why neil
has
a sleep tape that goes man what the hell
is your problem
can you see me crossing the street i'm
walking over here
i'm over here right that's my sleep tape
that's his sleeve
it allows me to sleep all right all
right all right
let's keep going let's keep going here
we go um
oh my goodness where's this great
question where are you
beth tomlinson says this from facebook
do marine mammals have
different ways of communicating
depending upon where they are
in the world or their geography for
example a dolphin in the gulf coast
uh will does it make different sounds
than a dolphin in the pacific
um or or does that differentiate itself
across different types of dolphins so do
dolphins have a universal language or do
they have dialects
that's what it really comes down to yeah
yeah that's that's really the simplest
way to put that
yeah and i they we think they have
dialects and even
yeah so if we have and that's but we've
sort of seen evidence for that for many
many years
um but they also so they have we don't
know if there's certain signals
that they share as well so for example
that means across groups of dolphins
it's something that a lot of us are
looking at
um humpback whales for example have
make these beautiful haunting songs many
of you may be familiar with that
and i saw star trek four
yeah save the whales there you go
that's good chuck chuck watch out the
jump on land and find you
i'll go to my door it'll be a hump back
there
like you rank i like that imitation
chuck that's beautiful
um but they change over seasons without
in a group of whales but in different
parts of the world the songs are
different for the humpbacks with
dolphins
they not only may have different signals
within the populations
but the range of the sounds they make
the frequencies are different we did a
study out of my lab several years ago
and we showed that bottlenose dolphins
in bimini
use whistles that are extend over a
wider frequency range
than in other groups so it may have to
do with their environment and what the
soundscape like you were talking about
neil is
you know they're they're they're they're
uh the window that they use
maybe it's yeah friends we're in the
infancy of those studies
and really some of them just have
russian accents and have spanish accents
that's really all it is
to them that's all it is that's
that would be amazing you know it's just
the dolphins just like hey man
how are you doing all right um
here we go the cheech and chong dolphin
that's a different dolphin right
exactly do you know real quick you know
dolphins can make two sounds at the same
time
there's a little piece of information
you might not have known
that's pretty cool well is one can they
make one out of their blowhole and one
out of the throat or the throat
the blowhole has two it's like two two
pot two holes
that make up the blowhole and each one
there are two sacks in each
so they can click and whistle at the
same time we showed in our lab too that
they can whistle they could do two
whistle and squawk at the same time it's
really cool
wow is that their version of walking and
chewing gum
at the same time no idea all right here
we go
okay time for like two fast ones chuck
here we go hello dr tyson dr reese
um it has been stated who is this who
said this
oh i'm sorry their name is this is uh
don rem from facebook connery
yes and don says this it is said that
math is a universal language which is
um the basis of which
the numerals zero through nine
the origins of that number system has to
do with the digits that we carry on our
hands
would an intelligent species share our
same mathematics even if they had a
different amount of digits or no digits
at all
i can comment on that i don't know it
dana
can dolphins count oh yeah there's been
evidence that they can track
uh numbers of items and and then and
they can they can
discern quantity differences several
okay and that's really all that counts
that's really all that counts correctly
where are the foods the base system you
use is actually doesn't matter if you
don't track of a number right
and what we presume in my field is
since any other number
base system would be arbitrary based on
you have 12 fingers 10 fingers six
fingers if you were going to communicate
you would de-arbitrize it and just use
base two
which is the smallest base you can use
where you can meaningfully count
and so so base two that's why all
computing is base two there's one
reason for that zeros and ones so you'd
say
no matter how many fingers you had let's
use base two and that would be the
fallback
for what this would be yeah
so chuck we have time for one more just
last one all right
this is rasha chuck hardy
i think from facebook hi dr tyson dr
reese greetings from
india have we really been able to
comprehend fully the ways
animals communicate among one another
truly owing
centuries of evolution and sustaining
very many
calamities under the water their
communication
would have been more complex for even
the human brain to understand
so you know is it the fact that they've
been here a lot longer than we have
could that mean that they're speaking in
a language that that we're incapable of
comprehending
we're just too stupid to figure it out
right we are not very far ahead
with that i have to say so i tend to
agree i think we don't know how complex
it is
is the best way i can say it it may be
quite complex
it's a challenge for us to decode it has
people have tried for a long time
we're still trying but i think uh we
still have a long way to go
as carl sagan famously said uh we judge
animals by how well they can communicate
with us dolphin could but we never
judge ourselves for how well we can
speak dolphin
yeah i actually think dolphins no i have
to say
i think dolphins have come a bit further
than we have in terms of
figuring it out excellent excellent and
just just to take us out
um i think that the the whale has the
the biggest
mammal brain the elephant brain is
pretty big as well where's the elephant
on the
encephalone
[Music]
yeah the encephalitis quotient
sounds bad when you say it that way i
don't do anything with an itis is bad
but go
right so the elephant at brain is about
similar
uh in relative size to its body as the a
great eight brain
greater great apes great apes or brains
relative to the
the size of the body are um are about
2.2.3
remember dolphins are about four point
two humans are seven elephants are about
two point three
and diane it does sound like you guys
invented this eq
to give more credit to these other
mammals
because for the longest while while we
all grew up it was humans have the
largest brain relative to our body
weight to any animal
even even dolphins right so any other
animal would look at humans as having
these stupidly large heads
right compared to our bodies so then you
come up with this other measure which is
what is the minimum brain to run the
body anything in excess of that
that's really your intelligence exactly
well it at least gives us an
idea of it gives us a comparison okay it
doesn't mean
it equates with intelligence is there
any animal whose brain is not big enough
to control its own body
i don't know of that i don't i have no
idea i think most animals are
controlling their body in some way
really you've got so the ratio can never
go
yeah i'm sorry i know some people who i
don't think are controlling their own
bodies
not directly related to brain size so
the ratio can never get less than one
on that well that yeah one it would be
the lowest yeah right right okay just
checking that
diana it's been great to have you here
on a topic that we've all thought about
but never had an expert to to anchor us
and so
chuck we as you said earlier we got to
do this again we gotta yeah
i bet we have many many more questions
we didn't even get to they were great
questions thanks so much for having me
and thanks everybody out there
excellent excellent so uh dan reese and
again your book
uh give us the title of that again it's
called the dolphin in the mirror
the dolphin in the mirror let's look for
that and chuck always good to have you
always good to be here
all right this has been star talk cosmic
queries the
interspecies communication edition i'm
neil degrass tyson
you're a personal astrophysicist bidding
you to keep looking up
[Applause]
[Music]